20 million people in the uk have now
received their first covert jab
well in a statement the health secretary
said well over a third of all adults
have now received the first dose of a
covert 19 vaccine
in every corner of the uk every jab in
the arm is another life soon to be
protected from this awful disease
and means we are a step closer to
returning to our normal lives
well joining me now is sky's ender
braider under brady that is he's at a
vaccine center outside coventry so ender
this speaks to the success of the
vaccine rollout and the
organization behind it
yeah it's a huge milestone really very
very significant day
indeed i think britain is now the envy
of europe certainly shooting ahead in
terms of numbers 20 million
jabs have now been delivered we're here
in binly just outside coventry
500 people booked in here today they've
been jabbing away since 8 a.m and they
will keep going now until
6 p.m a thousand people went through
here on friday
it's extremely well organized the supply
of the vaccine
has been absolutely crucial but the real
sense you get from speaking to people
here
is a pride in in their work in the
volunteering and just
everyone coming together all of the
different organizations
in this community working towards the
common good so
great pride here today and amongst the
patients i spoke to people coming in
getting the job a huge sense of relief
as well and we can have a listen now to
some of the patients we spoke to
a short time ago obviously there's a
long way to go everywhere in the
community but um yeah
the risk is still out there but i do
feel more protected now
it's something we should be extremely
proud of as a nation it's uh
very well done very well organized and
with the way things are going it's good
to have some positive news yeah
fantastic
i've got two small kids so getting the
jabs are being quite a big thing you
must be relieved
i'm very relieved i was really excited
to have the vaccine so
yeah feels like we're on the road to
normal
[Laughter]
definitely
so phase one of the vaccine rollout is
very much on track to be completed by
the middle of april and then we will
move into phase two
and the plan is for every single adult
in britain
to have been offered a first job of the
vaccine by the end of july